I'm going to get I think I'm very far
and very close sonic swing
I love patience I got a lot of things in
place on third base that I haven't
cashed in on and a lot of things I can
do is tomorrow it has to happen calling
a little people call in all those favors
cash in all those chips sell all but you
know my company just in a huge
transaction it's that valued
accompanying a four hundred million
dollar valuation that puts my network at
200 million of what I own of that I've
got all this paper money on Facebook I
can cash it all in it's on the stock
market I got private money and over and
other things and I can convert to
somebody else I've got pieces but what
he's not selling and the truth is I
don't have the 2.7 billion I'm nowhere
close to that now and I don't want to go
round up a lot of people to be a partner
I want a run [ __ ] I need to win a Super
Bowl so the good news is he's still
young he's you know I wish him help
every single day I need about another I
would love to have another 15 to 20
years to make the play but the truth is
I mean the journey to try to buy them
that's the game after game you know